how much wealth does the new king of
England have after training for the
position for more than 70 years King
Charles III inherited large swaths of
land Regal Estates rare Jewels paintings
and other personal property some going
back centuries from his mother Queen
Elizabeth II he also now oversees the
late Monarch's 42 billion dollar
portfolio of assets held in trust for
the kingdom including billions in
Investments and other opulent palaces
glittering jewels and Priceless art that
he will never actually own Her Majesty's
will is expected to be sealed for at
least 90 years so the exact distribution
of her assets will not be known for
several Generations but as her eldest
son Charles inherited the Queen's
private Estates her much-loved castle in
Balmoral Scotland where she died as well
as Sandringham in eastern England home
to the thoroughbred horse farm known as
the Royal studs
King Charles is also expected to inherit
her enormous private collection of
jewelry art rare stamps and any personal
Investments
altogether Forbes values these personal
assets at 500 million dollars
and Charles won't have to pay a shilling
of inheritance tax thanks to a 1993
agreement with the British government
that exempts transfers of property from
One Sovereign to another
the 73 year old Monarch has money of his
own mostly through the lucrative annual
income he received from the duchy of
Cornwall
he earned 27 million dollars this year
which his eldest son Prince William will
now inherit as Prince of Wales Charles
launched several Ventures to protect the
environment and Foster organic farming
through his charitable Foundation which
William also inherits Charles owns the
largest organic food brand in the UK as
well as a nature Retreat and Craft
Center in Transylvania that each operate
as bed and breakfasts Prince William
will now take possession of the duchy of
Cornwall a conglomerate with 1.2 billion
dollars in net asset as the new monarch
Charles assumes ownership of
Institutions that manage an estimated 42
billion dollars in assets these assets
including Buckingham Palace Windsor
Castle and the Tower of London aren't
held directly by the king but are
instead owned by the reigning monarch
quote in right of the crown for the
duration of their reign so what is it
all worth the single most valuable asset
held by King Charles is the crown estate
a sprawling real estate portfolio with
17.5 billion dollars in net assets
but the royal family also gets a cut in
the form of allowance from the treasury
known as The Sovereign Grant this is 25
of the net profit for the financial year
two years earlier in 2022 The Sovereign
Grant amounted to 99.6 million dollars
however that enormous windfall doesn't
go directly to Charles
a 10 cut of that net profit 39.8 million
dollars for 2022 is set aside for
maintaining Buckingham Palace and an
additional 15 is used to finance the
Royal Family's annual Travel formal
events housekeeping and payroll the most
expensive trip taken by the Royals in
the past year was Prince William and
Kate's nine-day visit to Belize Jamaica
and the Bahamas in March which cost
roughly two hundred and sixty thousand
dollars The Sovereign Grant isn't
Charles's only source of income the
duchy's net revenues go directly to the
king as an allowance called the privy
purse which covers any other official
expenditures in 2022 that amounted to 24
million dollars pre-tax
unlike The Sovereign Grant which is
tax-free the queen agreed in 1993 to
voluntarily pay income tax on the
portion of the privy purse not used for
official purposes in addition to the
crown estate and the duchy of Lancaster
Charles also holds the crown estate
Scotland a portfolio with some 570
million dollars in net assets the crown
jewels are perhaps the most identifiable
asset associated with the British royal
family according to a 2017 report the
Royal collection including the crown
jewels is estimated to be worth 12.7
billion dollars
there are also at least nine palaces
castles and Residences owned by the king
entrust as Sovereign or quote in right
of the crown Forbes estimates the
combined value of these properties at
9.5 billion dollars
as King Charles now holds 500 million
dollars in personal assets with another
42 billion dollars held in trust as the
sovereign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]